adam était un enfant comme les autres
mais un jour il découvre la vérité sur
ses origines et décide de partir à
l'aventuré
et quelle aventure
vous êtes qui je sais pas comment te le
dire mais je suis ton père mon père
c'est le big foot me qu'est ce qui
pourrait m'arriver de pire ailleurs est
ce que je vais devenir comme toi déjà dû
remarquer des changements comme les
cheveux qui pousse de 10 centimes dans
la nuit au où les pieds qui sortent tout
à fait des chaussures et c'est pas tout
tu peux aussi parler aux animaux la
forme les gars ravi de rencontrer petit
j'ai dû fuir parce qu'on voulait ma peau
ces gens ne reculeront devant rien pour
avoir ce qu'ils veulent
t'as pas besoin d'union notre seule
chance de réussir 7,6 m tous ensemble
vous êtes tous pris je suis toujours
prêt laissons faire les professionnels
m
ja
alors ça ne me suis jamais senti aussi
big foot junior au cinéma le 16 août